You’re in a part of town
you used to live in as a teenager.
You walk past the house of the girlfriend
you knew when you were 16.
You look up to what used to be
her bedroom window.
From the outside,
everything still looks the same
though somebody else lives there now.
Her parents are retired, she’s married
with two small kids in another city.
You feel a searing nostalgia for
everything that was and no longer is.
It’s not so much her you miss,
more what you had, who you both were,
how things looked then.
It’s hard to explain what the feeling is,
though it is confounding in its intensity.
At that moment, your phone rings.
It’s a friend – who asks how you are.
You’re at a loss, you don’t quite
know how to convey your emotions
and after a few attempts,
move on to other subjects.
Unless – that is – you speak Portuguese,
because if you do,
there will be no need to struggle.
You will have the ideal word
immediately to hand.
You will simply tell your friend
that you are experiencing ‘saudade’
and they will understand.
The word, which has no direct translation
in any other language,
means a bitter-sweet melancholic yearning
for something beautiful that is now gone:
a love affair, a childhood home,
a friendship.
It’s a blend of pain at loss and pleasure
that loveliness once graced our lives.
The underlying issue,
the relationship between
language and feeling,
has long created debate in philosophy.
Some thinkers have proposed that
feelings are independent of words:
babies, for example, can feel things
long before they know how to
pin words to their sensations.
But other philosophers have insisted
that certain feelings
would remain essentially unknown to us
if we didn’t have the words
to help us recognise them.
The truth – as so often – lies somewhere
in an intriguing middle zone.
Language may not wholly create feelings,
but it most definitely and beautifully
deepens and clarifies them.
The right words help us to know ourselves;
through their agency,
we can more accurately and securely
identify the contents of our inner lives.
The phenomenon becomes
particularly apparent
whenever we come across words
in other languages
that zero in on a feeling that our own
language doesn’t have a succinct term for.
We notice then just how much a good word
can do to bring an emotion into focus.
Take, for example, the Turkish word HÜZÜN,
which refers to the gloomy feeling
that things are in decline
and that the situation – often political
in nature – will probably only get worse,
typically because of the folly and
grandiosity of corrupt political leaders.
How useful to have such a word to
indicate, and commune with,
the depths of grief unfolding
in the Turkish soul.
Or, more cheerily, up in Norway
they have FORELSKET,
a word that captures the euphoric feeling
at the beginning of love,
when we can’t believe someone so perfect
could have wandered into our lives
and has the goodness to think well of us.
We might report: ‘I was overpowered
by forelsket as our fingers enlaced…’
But it isn’t just a few magical words from
foreign languages that clarify our minds.
This is what all great literature may do.
What we call a ‘good’ poem or novel
is ultimately one that reduces
the extent of our own
self-alienation and misunderstanding,
and returns us to ourselves.
After a lifetime of reading,
we might know how to
pin words and sentences
to pretty much everything we feel,
however ephemeral and fragile it might be.
It was this gift that Shakespeare praised
in A Midsummer Night’s Dream
when he wrote that:
The poet’s eye, in fine frenzy rolling,
Doth glance from heaven to earth,
from earth to heaven;
And as imagination bodies forth
The forms of things unknown, the poet’s pen
Turns them to shapes and
gives to airy nothing
A local habitation and a name.
Thanks to literature, we can be
rescued from the closed diving-bells
we are otherwise locked into.
The right words break our isolation.
They are the agents of,
and conduits to, love.